punishment of space force and the
establishment of space command
the united states is now doing what it
needs to do to protect our assets in
space and ensure that space
remains the heavens by which we not only
protect america but we sustain our
economy we sustain our commercial
capabilities
we sustain americans way of life so
again another very historic moment
i'm confident that both the space force
and the space command will do what is
necessary to defend us in space
and to keep america great thank you very
much
great job you're doing too general milly
please
sir thank you mr president and uh as
secretary said this is a historic day
uh some time ago uh we made a decision
to establish
uh the space force and that's because we
are undergoing a changing character of
war
which is of historic importance for all
nations
and as part of that the space
part of our universe opened up as a
domain of warfare
and it's critical that if we are going
to sustain our way of life if we're
going to defend our nation
that we're going to have to defend
ourselves in space
and therefore the need for space for us
and it's a it's a great day for the
nation it's a great day really for the
world
that the united states of america
establishes its first space sport
thank you very much please mr president
thank you for your leadership
congratulations thank you number one yes
sir
i appreciate the honor 16 000 space
professionals assigned to the space
force
we're proud of this flight they come to
work every day
focusing on providing space capabilities
for our nation for our joint coalition
forces
and for the world we're proud of this
flag we're proud to have an opportunity
to present it to you here
for display in the white house thank you
thank you for your question appreciate
it
secretary please thank you mr president
you've really demonstrated leadership in
establishing the space
force this is an important moment an
important month
actually most of the americans before
the first cup of coffee in the morning
have used
space but very few people realize how
important space is
to everything that we do and that it's
vulnerable
as we need to up our game in space and
you've
recognized that and built a force that
will help to protect
our assets in space and deter
aggressive action in space and if
deterrence doesn't work
to be able to defend our assets in space
and those of our
allies so we thank you very much for the
leadership you've demonstrated
and we're excited for this breakthrough
moment well thank you very much i
appreciate it we're building right now
incredible military equipment
at a level that nobody's ever seen
before we have no choice we have to do
it
with the adversaries we have out there
we have uh
i call it the super duper missile and i
heard the other night
17 times faster than what they have
right now then you take the fastest
missile we have right now
uh you've heard russia has five times
and china's working on five or six times
we have won 17 times
and it's just gotten the go-ahead
17 times faster if you can believe that
general that's something right
17 times faster than what we have right
now fastest in the world by a factor of
almost three
so i just want to congratulate everybody
and thank everybody
space is going to be it's going to be
the future
both in terms of defense and offense and
so many other things and already
from what i'm hearing and based on
reports we're now the leader in space
and that
took place don't forget we're having a
meeting today this is really to unfurl
the flag but we've been doing this now
for
quite a while i have to say that from my
standpoint having
a a force a
space force in this case but to be
adding to the joint chiefs of staff
which i've known about and read about
and
heard about all my life just like
general milley to be the head of the
joint chiefs of staff is something
that's a very special thing well
to add another force into the joint
chiefs and uh
and we're getting a uh a four-star
in this case we're getting a four-star
general on your board
so we're doing something right here so
we're doing something that
is such a monumental task so it's been
more than 72 years the air force
i believe was the last one and so we
have air force and not since the air
force has anything like this happened
and now we have space force added on
with with full honors i must add
with full honors so today we're here for
a uh
very important it's really an important
occasion because we're unfurling
the flag and with us is chief master
sergeant roger
toberman and he is uh
i'd like you to say exactly because his
rank is a very special rank
uh tell us about that rank yes sir i'm
the senior enlisted advisor for the
united states space force
the highest highest sergeant by far
right
yes sir and at the moment the only one
so i give
counsel to the secretariat president uh
this rank is custom designed
wow that's great wow that's it and he's
the only
the only airman that wears that ring and
will be the only
chairman that wears that rank he's the
senior english understand jason and i
heard tremendous things about you roger
it's very important position thank you
you're with all these generals but you
know what
he's an important guy right so why don't
we go ahead and do it
let's do it yes please
that's fantastic
is
that's fantastic and then great please
get in the picture that's beautiful
mr president will stand in your office
alongside the other service flags
very very great honor it's a great honor
that's a beautiful flag too
roger hold that up so they can see
that's really beautiful
it's a big that's a big day that's a big
day
delta in the middle is a symbol that
the space community has used for years
and years and years
the north star signifies our core value
or guiding light
if you will and the orbit around the
globe
signifies the space capabilities that
fuel our american way life and our
american way of war
i'm going to do this for roger here
roger
please don't put this on ebay tonight
yeah roger come here
and we're gonna sign
okay roger
that's for you thank you so much thank
you thank you very much
okay so let's do it this is great stuff
okay let's see i have i think we have no
choice right general
come on over here good luck thank you
good luck
okay fantastic and these are those
okay thank you thank you very thank you
very much roger
thank you very much mark you're all set
general come on over here
general kellogg's been fantastic done a
great job he's working on a special
project now aren't you all right i'm
sure we're getting this
very special project okay
[Applause]
okay got it thank you all very much
thank you
i'll be going to camp david tonight with
a lot of different people we have some
big
things happening so be camp david
tonight with
various people various people including
some
some of the folks on the hill and some
of our
great leaders different things
different uh no not so much facebook
facebook could happen but it'll happen
the right way
we have all the cards because we have
the cards for the american people i know
what they want
and i've always known what they want
that's why i'm sitting here
now phase four is going to happen but
it's going to happen in a much better
way for the american people okay
thank you all very much thank you very
much
thank you very much thank you all
right we're done let's go chris thank
you very much
thank you
you